e aí
e eu vou começar a contando a história
de um contrato celebrado na frança em
1965 o advogado de 47 anos de idade
doutor andré françois conheci uma
velhinha de 90 anos de idade que vivia
sozinha na casa dela em arlei no sul da
frança e ele propôs para ela um acordo
ele pagaria para ela uma importância
mensal 2.500 francos o que era menos um
aluguel todos os meses para o resto da
vida dele mas quando ela morresse a casa
seria dele enquanto ela fosse viva
usufruto total da casa era dela mas
quando ela morresse a casa seria dele cá
entre nós um negócio da china a pobre
diane vivendo crepúsculo de seus 90 anos
e sem descendente direto acabou
aceitando
e o advogado sabia que dentro de pouco
tempo ele seria o feliz proprietário de
uma casa e pagando muito pouco por isso
três longos anos se passaram três longos
anos até que em 1968 a frança foi
chacoalhada por uma série de protestos
no famoso maio de 1968 mas a velhinha
não foi chacoalhada mais um ano se
passou até que em 1969 o homem pisou na
lua pela primeira vez newarmistron
flutuava com os pés no ar enquanto a
velhinha que dava filho no chão mais um
ano se passou até que em 1970 o brasil
se tornou tricampeão do mundo de futebol
e a velinha mais ligeira que o peleco
e você pode está achando que eu estou
enrolando vocês longe de mim porque
vocês não querem saber da história do
mundo vocês querem saber é da história
da vida da velhinha ou talvez do
contrário da vida e para falar da vida
da velhinha eu vou transportar vocês até
1975 quando a velhinha finalmente fez
100 anos de vida comemorou seus 100 anos
de vida nunca passou pela cabeça do
advogado que ela iria virar uma
centenária uma década de contrato
pagando a mensalidade sem nunca poder
tomar um chá com uma delícia na sua casa
bem arlei o advogado já estava três e
ritter com os acontecimentos ou melhor
como não acontecimento ele tão
acostumado aos habeas corpus queria
mesmo era enterra corpos
e foi então que ele decidiu dar uma de
joão-sem-braço aí fazer uma visitinha
para velhinha ele foi na casa dela
encontrou ela na varanda fumando fumando
feito uma chaminé em volta numa nuvem de
fumaça tão grossa mas tu não gosta que
mais parecia um ensaio do plano esse rap
há um século de vida e fumando desse
jeito essa história não pode durar para
sempre foi então que o doutor andré eu
vou com os seus mais elevados
pensamentos cristãos e fez uma prece
senhor olhar e pelas pessoas simples que
mesmo fazendo hora extra na terra abusam
da dádiva percebida em atitudes
imprudentes para a saúde leva ela levar
ela ao teu encontro para que ela possa
usufruir da tranquilizante música das
harpas celestiais
é provável que deus não tenho vida essa
pressa absurda que nada aconteceu nos
anos que se seguiram foi só em 1980 que
o advogado não teve coragem de fazer os
cálculos 15 anos de contrato 180
prestações ele já tinha gasto mais do
que custaria a casa se ele tivesse
comprado no mercado imobiliário bom essa
história tá ficando comprida eu tô morto
de cansado haveria não morre então você
levar para vocês beleza 1981 82 83 84 85
86 87 88 89 89 enfim caiu o muro de
berlim ea zelinha forte feita uma
muralha 90 morreu não morreu 91 morreu
não morreu 92 morreu não morreu 93 não
morreu 94 não morreu 95 sim definir
aleluia irmãos o fim chega para todos
ninguém dura para sempre
do babau já elvis demorou #lacrou morreu
e justamente no natal de 1995 morreu aos
77 anos de idade 77 sim porque quem
morreu não foi a velhinha foi o advogado
e lá se foi doutor andré françoar ouvida
tranquilizante música das harpas
celestiais #partiu e a velhinha vivinha
da silva e dona da casa que continuaria
sendo dela
e essa é uma história real e os próximos
números que eu vou mostrar para vocês
também há 5.000 anos homosapiense
egípcios construíram as pirâmides do
egito no século 20 homosapiens
estatísticos construíram as pirâmides
demográficas as monumentais pirâmides
egípcias continuam de pé mas as
pirâmides demográficas estão acabando e
por conta de dois fatores durante muito
tempo a gente utilizou pirâmide
demográfica para se referir a
distribuição da população de acordo com
a idade porque crianças e jovens que
ficam aqui na parte de baixo sempre
foram muito mais numerosas que adultos e
idosos que ficam aqui na parte de cima
só que agora está mudando primeiro
porque a gente vive cada vez mais e vai
viver ainda mais e dois porque a gente
tem cada vez menos filhos as famílias
estão menores os casais têm cada vez
menos filhos
a e agora os casais se tranca no quarto
e passa a noite toda em maratonas
maratona de séries da netflix portanto a
tendência que faço ainda menos beleza
vamos ver como estão as pirâmides
demográficas do brasil esta pirâmide do
brasil de 1980 uma clássica pirâmide
muita criança embaixo muito adolescente
e poucos idosos vejam como mudou a
pirâmide demográfica atual de 2019 tá
bem menos crianças em muita gente em
idade economicamente ativa o brasil tá
vendo se fechar a janela do bônus
demográfico mas para aproveitar o bônus
demográfico o brasil precisaria fazer
sua lição de casa investir na juventude
ter um sistema de ensino efetivamente de
qualidade fomentar a inovação eo
empreendedorismo e ter boa governança
dos recursos públicos atributos que nem
sempre a gente encontra por aqui com a
gente sabe o brasil
é uma oportunidade de perder uma
oportunidades
a e agora é a pirâmide do brasil
projetada de 2050 tá com menos crianças
e muito mais pessoas maduras e idosas
vamos ver agora o que vai acontecer com
cada grupo etário no brasil no intervalo
de meio século no ano 2000 até o ano
2050 vejam que a gente já cumpriu quase
metade dessa trajeto olha o que vai
acontecer com as crianças de 0 a 9 anos
elas são reduzirem trinta e dois por
cento
é isso significa que para cada três
crianças que nós temos no ano 2000
teremos apenas duas no ano 2050 um terço
das crianças vai desaparecer eu fico
preocupado com o futuro sem criança qual
será o futuro da galinha pintadinha
o e os adolescentes de 10 a 19 o que que
vai acontecer com esse grupo vai reduzir
trinta por cento quase igual as crianças
população adulta de 20 a 49 vai aumentar
onze por cento e agora se preparem para
revolução e prateada população de 50 ou
mais vai aumentar 286 por cento da
população de 60 ou mais vai aumentar 416
por cento
oi e a população de 90 ou mais vai
aumentar 3426 por cento isso significa
que para cada velhinho nonagenário que
tinhamos no ano 2000 teremos 34 no ano
2050 no futuro um homo sapiens será cada
vez mais um o silver um homem grisalho
um homem prateado porque essas
tendências não são apenas brasileiras
são mundiais o mundo todo está
envelhecendo a gente todo mundo nota a
disrupção tecnológica uma descrição
barulhenta mas talvez seja importante
que a gente olha também a disrupção
demográfica que lentamente toma conta do
mundo as oportunidades dessa nova
configuração populacional são imensas
mas muita gente não percebe ou finge não
perceber então visse porque a gente
ainda tenha uma narrativa cultural e
preconceito em relação envelhecimento a
gente associa o envelhecimento apenas um
de cada
e com perda isso não é verdade e a
ciência mostra isso pode ser que a gente
atingir o nosso auge atlético aos 26
anos de idade mais uma das provas mais
extenuantes do atletismo o teca aeron
atletas ao redor de 40 anos parecem se
sair melhor que mede a maioria dos
ganhadores do prêmio nobel feito a
principal descoberta após os 40 anos a
gente obtém uma melhor capacidade de
entender as nossas emoções e as emoções
alheias a partir dos 50 e tem um estudo
que diz que a gente consegue manejar
melhor o vocabulário aos 67 anos de
idade mas talvez o maior a linha qo
mesmo seja achar que existe uma terceira
idade o quê velho é tudo igual não é nem
nunca será são muitos os tons de prata
em primeiro lugar porque esse segmento
enorme de 50 milhões de pessoas
incorporam as mesmas discrepâncias que
existem no brasil desigual que a gente
vive gente com muita
a saúde gente com alta e com baixa
escolaridade sente ativa e gente nativa
gente com a situação financeira
invejável e gente que vive o crepúsculo
de seus dias no limiar da indigência tem
de tudo em segundo lugar porque à medida
que o tempo passa a gente vai
incorporando mais traços próprios da
nossa biografia de vida ou seja nós
vamos nos tornando seres mais complexos
e únicos o que a gente precisa mesmo é
se despir dos preconceitos e dos
estereótipos estereótipos negativos e
positivos também se existe um monte de
bom velhinho bonzinho tipo o papai noel
mas tem velhinho que não presta também
porque os cafagestes também é sem
e tem um monte de vovózinha fazendo
tricô e crochê e bolinho de fubá para os
netinhos mas tem muita vovózinha também
aplicativo de paquera e que já
experimentou quase todas as posições do
kama sutra inclusive a tesoura invertida
que é complicadíssima
não tem jeito de 50 que não vê a hora de
parar e jeito de 70 que não para de
empreender e um monte de aposentado que
não quer ficar no aposento pessoas que
querem sentir ativa e contribuindo com o
mundo talvez a gente descubra um dia que
não existe velho ou jovem 100 pessoas
seres humanos sempre contradições
defeitos e qualidades únicos em sua
infinita individualidade e que não podem
ser encaixotados em rótulos ou etiquetas
etárias aliás falando em caixote todo
mundo fala a gente tem que sair da caixa
mas tudo que mundo faz desde que a gente
nasce vai colocar a gente dentro de
caixa
e durante muito tempo a vida foi
encaixotada em três fases como se fosse
assim dos ela os sete a fase de brincar
dos 7 aos 22 faz estudar os 22 a 55 fase
de trabalhar e depois se preparar para
ouvir as harpas celestiais
é só que a gente ganha um bônus de 20
anos de longevidade isso muda tudo a
gente vai ter que estudar para o resto
da vida seremos eternos aprendizes
porque a fila tá andando depressa demais
ao mesmo tempo a vida laboral será mais
intensa mais gerações trabalharam juntas
no mercado de trabalho e a gente vai
poder ter aposentadorias intermediárias
como muita gente já faz uns anos
sabáticos para repensar a vida se
reinventar ou poder uma transição de
carreira que a gente coloca no linkedin
quando fica desempregada
e a gente vai poder brincar na fase de
aprender aprender na fase de trabalhar
aposentar temporariamente na fase de
trabalhar e empreender na fase de
aposentar tudo-ao-mesmo-tempo-agora e a
gente vai ter que resolver o problema
que é da paz sincronia entre o trabalho
ea vida pessoal normalmente a fase em
que a gente mais investe na carreira
entre os 28 e 45 anos de idade é o
período que coincide com a maternidade
ou paternidade e no momento que seus
filhos estão implorando pelo convívio
dos pais mães fica comigo o mercado de
furador de almas está exigindo 247 por
cento que você não é à toa que tem tanta
gente angustiada nessa fase tanta
criança sendo criada pelo celular e
tanta gente desistindo da maternidade e
os consultórios psicológicos nunca
estiveram tão cheios de pessoas se
sentindo vazias
e aí quando você tem lá pelos seus 50
anos de idade seus filhos se transformar
em aborrecente e tudo que eles não
querem os pais por perto porque nessa
hora seus filhos te acham feio fica
piorar o rh também taxa velha mas velho
mesmo é o nosso preconceito a gente
precisa dar um jeito nessa situação
afinal de contas para tudo se dá um
jeito na vida menos para morte né
ah sei lá foi assim até hoje mas já tem
cientista sério dizendo que no futuro a
gente vai dar um jeitinho na morte que a
gente vai viver acima dos 1000 anos e
que o destino do homo sapiens é ser
imortal
a viver muito é bom mas sinceramente eu
acho que o número tão próximo da
infinitude talvez desvirtue a lógica
sobre a qual a gente construiu a nossa
civilização e as nossas frágeis certezas
saber que a gente tem data de validade
aqui nesse admirável planetinha azul é
sempre uma fonte de angústia mas ao
mesmo tempo é um forte estímulo para que
a gente se motive a trabalhar buscar um
propósito e deixar o legado além do mais
já pensou conviver com a sogra por 900
anos viver muito é bom mas deixemos a
imortalidade por hora sua ficção
científica porque mais do que uma vida
cumprida a gente quer mesmo uma vida
cumprida hoje a nossa missão de vida
seja cumprida uma vida que vale a pena
ser vivida
a medida comprida tv linha que que
aconteceu com a velhinha quando advogado
morreu jornalistas do mundo todo foram
procurar procurar lá perguntando o que
ela tinha achado daquele contrato aí ela
falou assim é às vezes as pessoas fazem
maus negócios madame jeanne faleceu em
1997 dois anos depois do advogado ela
morreu com 122 anos e foi a pessoa que
mais viveu em toda a história da
humanidade e o advogado doutor andré
françois ré foi provavelmente o advogado
mais azarado da história não são
fornecidas pela coisa que ele assinou
com a jane cauã os herdeiros dele
tiveram que continuar pagando todo mês a
velhinha até o fim da vida dela para que
eles pudessem finalmente é da casa o que
só aconteceu em agosto de 1997 doutor
andré rass
tu apostou na lógica das probabilidades
tão golpe de azar um desvio estático se
ela vir mas em pleno século 21 não faz
nenhum sentido apostar contra a
demografia quem apostar contra a
revolução da longevidade tá lá não
apenas sendo míope e negando os fatos
mas sobretudo perdendo grandes
oportunidades e fazendo um péssimo
negócio porque o futuro não é cinza o
futuro é prateado e os prateados valem
ouro muito obrigado a
e aí